สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครู
หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสดีค่ะนักเรียนครู
เรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
[เพลง]
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
16 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
พ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
เรียมตอนนี้ 9 น
32 นค่ะออเ 9:00 นครึ่งหน่อยๆ
932 ออใช่ค่ะหิวค่ะอุ้ยๆๆท้องร้องอุอัด
วีดีโอเสร็จเนี่ยต้องไปหาอะไรกินแล้วนะคะ
มีเงินหรือเปล่าคะจะไปซื้ออาหารกินเนี่ย
ไม่มี
เอ้าทำไมไม่มีเงินอ่ะไม่มีเงินก็ต้องมี
บัตร ATM มยบัตร ATM ไปที่ตู้ atm แล้วก็
กดเงินออก
มาบัต TM  ATM ตอนนี้เรียมหาหาไม่เจอ
อ้าวแล้วจะทำยังไงอ่ะคะหายหรอครูเรียมทำ
บัตร ATM หายเหรอ
คะไม่รู้นะคะแต่ถ้าเกิดหาไม่เจอก็คงจะ
หายใช่มยูหญิงแล้วถ้าบัตรคือครูหญิงอ่ะ
ไม่เคยทำบัตร ATM หายหรือว่าเคยว่ะแต่ว่า
เคยมีแบบคนคนรู้เป็นนาเป็นเป็นนักเรียน
น่ะเป็นนักเรียนเป็นเด็กๆอ่ะค่ะเค้าเนี่ย
ทำบัตร ATM หายอ่าแล้วเา้าก็ไปไปที่
ธนาคารเสชไปที่ธนาคารว่าบัตร ATM หายอ
เอ่อธนาคารก็ถามว่ามีสมุดบัญชีมั้ยเพราะ
ว่าเวลาไปธนาคารเนี่ยมันก็ต้องมีแบบสมุด
บัญชีเนาะแบบนี้สมุอ่ะเดี๋ยวให้นักเรียน
ดูภาพก็ไม่ชัดนะคะแบบเนี้ยนะคะใช่อ่าสมุด
บัญชีซึ่งเด็กอ่ะไม่รู้สมุดบัญชีอยู่ที่
ไหน
อืธนาคารก็เลยบอกว่าอุ๊ยถ้าอย่างงั้นก็ทำ
บัตร ATM ใหม่ไม่ได้ถ้าถ้าไม่มีสมุดบัญชี
คุณหญิงก็เลยถามว่าเ้าแล้วต้องทำยังไงคะ
ธนาคารก็บอกว่าก็ต้องไปที่สถานีตำรวจค่ะ
ต้องไปแจ้งความก่อนคุหญิงก็เรเคุหญิงก็
เลยบอกว่าทำบัตร ATM หายคือก็จะมีครูอีก 1
คนใช่มั้ยคะที่เขาเรียนมาเก็บอกว่าเรา
เนี่ยจะไปแจ้งความที่สถานีตำรวจใกล้ๆ
ออฟฟิศอเราก็ต้องบอกว่าบัตร ATM หายเนี่ย
ใกล้ๆกับออฟฟิศใช่อ่าถ้าบอกบัตร ATM หาย
ที่บางนาแล้วไปแจ้งความที่สถานีตำรวจแถวๆ
ออฟฟิศออฟฟิศอยู่กลางเมืองใช่มั้ยอยู่แถว
ๆสยามแจ้งได้มั้ยคะตำรวจก็จะบอกว่าไป
บางนาใช่ห้ามบอกนะว่าหายที่นี่คือบ้านน่ะ
อยู่บางนาไงห้ามบอกว่าหายที่บ้านอันอัน
นี้ไม่ได้โกหกนะคะนักเรียนแต่ตำรวจจะให้
เราไปจริงๆนะอันนี้เรื่องจริงอันนี้คือ
เรื่องจริงใช่มเพราะว่าก็เคยเจอมาแล้วอัน
นี้ยังดีที่แบบแค่ ATM อย่างเดียวที่
เรียมหาไม่เจอเรียมเคยแบบกระเป๋าเงินหาย
กระเป๋าตังค์หายแล้วมีทำแประชาชนกเออมี
อะไรบ้างใบขับขี่รถมอเตอร์ไซค์ใบขับขี่รถ
ยนต์มีบัตร
ATM เยอะมากบัตรเครดิตพเรียมไม่มีบัตร
เครดิตมี ATM ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็เลยต้องไปแจ้ง
ความที่สถานี
ตำรวจแต่บางทีเราก็เรียกโรงพักนะใช่รงพัก
สถานีตำรวจก็ไปแจ้งความกับตำรวจเหมือนกัน
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็บอกตำรวจตำรวจค่ะคะกระเป๋า
เงินหายตำรวจก็เลยบอกว่าคงไม่ได้คืนหรอก
อ้าอ้าเดี๋ยวตำรวจไม่ถามเหรอคะว่าหายที่
ไหนตำรวจก็ถามอยู่เพราะว่าเค้าต้องเขียน
เขียนลงในเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรนะอ่าใบใบแจ้ง
ความนะใบแจ้ง
ความใบแจ้งความสมุบกลงบันทึกเออเค้าเรียก
ว่าลงบันทึกเออบันทึกประจำวันของตำรวจนะ
คะเหมือนที่เค้าบันทึกไว้ว่าวันนี้มีใคร
มาแจ้งความบ้างอืเค้าเรียกว่าบันทึกประจำ
วันแล้วก็โอเคแจ้งแล้วเขาก็เขียนไว้ว่า
กระเป๋าเงินเาจะถามว่ากระเป๋าเงินหายเอ่อ
มีอะไรในกระเป๋าเงิน
บ้างเราก็จะบอกบัตประชาชนบัตร
ATM บัตรใบขับขี่ใบอนุญาตขับขี่มีเงินใน
นั้นกี่บาทอะไรประมาณเนี้ยเค้าก็จะถาม
เพราะว่าเค้าถามมั้ยว่ากระเป๋าสีอะไร
กระเป๋าสีอะไรหรอเดีมเค้าไม่เคยถามนะอ๋อ
ไม่รู้ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันถใช่ค่ะ
ไม่ไม่ถามแต่ว่า
แบบบอกแค่ว่าแบบเป็นกระเป๋าสะพายหรือว่า
เป็นกระเป๋าเป็นกระเป๋าเงินอะไรประมาณ
เนี้ยค่ะแล้วเขาคก็จะเขียนตอนหายที่ไหน
กี่โมงเดิมก็เลยคิดนะแบบหายที่ไหนถ้าเกิด
ถ้าเกิดเรานึกได้เราต้องหาเจอแล้ว
สิแต่ว่าบางทีมันอาจจะบางคนอาจจะรู้แล้ว
ก็อาจจะมีคนหยิบไปอ่ะมันก็เลยหาไม่เจอเขา
ก็เลยถามหายที่
ไหนใช่แล้วครูเหลี่ยมบอกว่าหายที่ไหน
เหลี่มก็บอกหายแบบแถวๆริมถนนค่ะเพราะว่า
เราต้องแจ้งความนะผู้หญิงเพราะว่ามันต้อง
เอาเอาใบแจ้งความเนี่ยไปทำบัตรประชาชนไป
ทำ ID การดใหม่ไปทำบัตร ATM ใหม่ไปทำใบ
ขับขี่
ใหม่อือเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดเราไปไปแบบที่ที่
เค้าทำทำบัตรประชาชนให้เราเค้าก็จะถามว่า
มีใบแจ้งความมั้ยคะถ้าเกิดเราบอกว่าบัตร
หายใช่ใช่ใช่เราก็เลยต้องไปสถานีตำรวจ
ก่อนอืนั่นแหละเรมแล้วครูเรียมอ่ะครู
เรี่มเคยไป
แจ้งเดี๋ยวนะค่ะเสียงยังไม่มาขอวังเสียง
ก่อนครูเรียมเนี่ยเคยไปแจ้งความที่สถานี
ตำรวจกี่ครั้ง่ะคะ
ห
ประมาณถ้าแจ้ง
ความ
ประมาณ 3  4 ครั้งประมาณ 4 ครั้งที่ไป
แจ้งความอุ้ยส่วนเหมือนกันหมดเลยมั้ยก็
คือของ
หายมีของหายประมาณ 2 ครั้งอ่ะของหาย 2
ครั้งแล้วก็มีโทรศัพท์หาย
อืโทรศัพท์หาย 1
ครั้งค่ะแล้วก็มีอะไรอีกอ่ะเงก็จำไม่ได้
ประเป๋าเงินหายบัตรหายประมาณนี้แหละแล้ว
ก็มีมีแบบไม่ได้ไปแจ้งความนะแต่ว่าไปจ่าย
จ่ายเงินค่าปรับอืถ้าจ่ายเงินค่าปรับก็
แปลว่าเราต้องทำอะไรผิดใช่มยตำรวจก็เลยมี
ใบมาหาเราใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเรียมขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ออกไปแล้วก็ไม่ใส่หมวกกันนาะ
อ๋อตำรวจก็เลย
เรียกจอดๆๆๆเข้าข้าง
ทางมานี่มานี่มานี่มาคุยกัน
หน่อยเออใช่ๆๆเก็โอเอาแล้วหมวกกันน็อหมวก
กันน็อคือบ้านเรียมอยู่ในเมืองแล้วเรียม
ก็คิดว่าขับออกไปนิดเดียวไปกินข้าวแต่ว่า
ขับออกไปแล้วก็ตำรวจแจ็คพอตใช่แจ็คพอต
แล้วเอาเงินมาเนี่ยนิดเดียวเพราะว่าคิดไป
กินข้าวนิดเดียว
อืความจริงแล้วตำรวจเคก็จะมีโต๊ะนะเก็จะ
มีโต๊ะแล้วเก็จะเขียนใบสั่งค่ะเรียมก็จะ
แบบอ่าชื่อเค้าก็จะถามว่าชื่อ
อะไรมีบัตรประชาชนมั้ยเอาบัตรประชาชนมา
เขาคก็จะเขียนๆๆจ่ายเงิน 200 เ๋ก็บอกไม่
มีเงินค่ะไม่มีเงิน
อมีเงิน 50 บาทค่ะตอนนี้อ้าแล้วแล้วตำรวจ
ทำยังไงอ่ะพอครูเรียมบอกตำรวจก็บอกว่าเอา
ใบสั่ง
เเอาใบสั่งไปจ่ายเงินที่สถานีตำรวจ
อ่าใช่ค่ะครูเรียมก็เลยต้องกลับ
บ้านไปเอาเงินไม่หรือว่าไปจ่ายวันอื่นก็
ได้ยังไปจ่ายวันอื่นอื่นเพราะว่าจำได้ว่า
ใบสั่งเนี่ยจะอยู่ได้ประมาณกี่วันอ่ะ
ประมาณกี่วัน 7 วันใช่มั้ยประมาณ 7 วัน
ประมาณ 7 วันก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันใบสั่งน่ะ
อยู่ได้ประมาณ 7 วันเราต้องไปจ่ายเงินภาย
ใน 7 วันอืเรียมก็โอเคเรียมมีใบสั่งอยู่ 7
วันถ้าตำรวจเรียกเรียมอีกเรียมก็จะบอกว่า
มีใบสั่งแล้ว
ไม่ต้องเรียกอีกแล้วนะไม่ต้องเรียกมีใบ
สั่งแล้วไม่ต้องไม่ต้องมีใบสั่ง 1 ใบ 2
ใบ 3 ใบแล้วก็ผิดเหมือนกันก็คือไม่ใส่
หมวกกันน็อคใช่แล้วก็แบบพอถึงประมาณวัน
ที่ 6 วันที่ 7 เรียมก็จะไปสถานีตำรวจไป
จ่ายเงินค่า
ปรับอันนี้ก็ถ้าครูเรียมไปจ่ายเงินค่า
ปรับเนี่ยครูเรียมไปถึงสถานีตำรวจแล้วก็
บอกเหรอคะว่ามาจ่ายเงินค่าปรับใช่ค่ะไป
สถานีตำรวจแล้วก็เอาเนี่ยเค้าเรียกว่า
อะไรนะเรียมพูดว่าอะไรนะเมื่อกี้ใบสั่งใบ
สั่งใบสั่งใช่มยเอาใบสั่งไปให้ตำรวจแล้ว
ก็บอกว่าจ่ายเงินค่าปรับค่ะแล้วก็เอาเงิน
ตำรวจตำรวจอ๋อแค่นั้นไม่ยากไม่ยากค่ะแต่
ว่าบางทีที่เรียมใส่หมวกอน็อออกไปตำรวจก็
ยังเรียกอยู่นะเรียกแบบเ้า
ทำไมอ่ะผิดอะไรอีกอ่ะก็ใส่หมวกกันน็อค
แล้วไงมีใบขับขี่มั้ย
อ๋อเพราะว่าขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะก็ต้องมีใบ
ใช่มยคะว่าูเรียมเนี่ยแล้วก็เป็นใบสำหรับ
ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์นั่นคือใบขับขี่เตอร์ไซค์
ใช่อืแล้วครูเรียมมีมั้ยบางวันวันที่
เรียมเอากระเป๋าเงินไปก็จะมีใบขับขี่เล็ม
ก็มีสบายอ่ะนี่ค่ะไปขับขี่วันไหนที่เรียม
ออกไปใส่หมวกกน็อคแต่ว่าเฮ้ยไม่ได้เอา
กระเป๋าเงินมาใบขับขี่อยู่ในกระเป๋าเงิน
เลมก็
โอ๊ยได้ใบสก็ไม่มีใบขับขี่ได้ใบถ้าไม่มี
ใบขับขี่อ่ะค่ะต้องจ่ายค่าปรับเท่าไหร่
อ่ะครูเรียมประมาณ 200 บาท
อืแต่ตำรวจก็ชอบเรียกมอเตอร์ไซค์จริงๆนะ
ใช่ๆใช่ครูหญิงเรียมได้ยินนักเรียนเล่ามา
บอกว่าถ้าเกิดเป็นฝรั่งเป็นชาวต่างชาตินะ
จ่ายแพงกว่าคนไทยอีกหรออาจจะต้องพูดภาษา
อังกฤษมั้งใช่ๆน่าจะพูดภาษาอังกฤษเคิดว่า
แบบคิดเออไม่รู้เรื่องใช่แล้วครูหญิงก็
เคยได้มีนักเรียนบอกเหมือนกันว่าบางที
ตำรวจอ่ะก็เหมือนแบบเล็งแต่คนต่างชาติที่
ขับรถก็มีคือพอเป็นคนไทยขับอ่ะไม่เรียก
ให้จอดแต่พอเห็นว่าเป็นคนต่างชาติอ่ะก็
เรียกแล้วก็ให้จอดอันนี้ไม่ใช่ขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ด้วยนะคะขับรถด้วยอ่ะเออใช่
แล้วก็มาขอค้นรถอ่ะคือนักเรียนเ้าก็งงไง
แบบเ้าขับจากกรุงเทพฯจะไปเที่ยวอย่าง
เงี้ยอื
ออก็แบบแต่ก็ไม่มีอะไรนะคะเพราะว่ามันไม่
มีอะไรไงอืใช่ก็ไม่ได้ไม่มีอะไรนะแต่ถ้า
เกิดเป็นมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยจะต้องจ่ายค่า
ปรับประมาณ 200  300 แต่ถ้าเป็นรถยนต์นะ
จ่ายค่าปรับประมาณ 500 บาทขึ้นไปนะ
เออใช่ใช่แพงกว่าเอใช่แพงกว่าประมาณนั้น
ค่ะคุณอแต่ว่านั่นแหละแต่คือครูหญิงอ่ะ
ไม่ได้เคยไปสถานีตำรวจหลายครั้งไงเคยไป
แค่ 1 ครั้งที่เล่าให้ฟังอ่ะว่าพานัก
เรียนใช่มั้ยไปแจ้งความสมุดบัญชีหายแล้ว
แบบคือตำรวจอ่ะเค้าดูเหมือนไม่อยากทำงาน
อ่ะอุยไม่รู้ว่าเวลากูเรียมไปเจอพเออเรา
พูดได้มยเราไม่ได้บอกว่าตำรวจที่ไหนอ๋อ
สถานีอะไรตำรวจมีเยอะมากสถานตมีนิดหน่อย
อาจจะมีนิดหน่อยที่ไม่อยากทำงานเออใช่ใช่
คืออันเนี้ยก็ไม่รู้ว่าเตั้งใจทำงานแล้ว
หรือเปล่านะแต่เขาก็เหมือนแบบ
อหายที่ไหนทำไมหายแล้วก็แบบพูดเหมือนแบบ
แล้วนี่ก็ไม่ใช่คนไทยใช่มั้ยคะแต่โอเคฟัง
ภาษาไทยได้พูดภาษาไทยได้เออก็ตอบเองได้
แต่บางครั้งก็ฟังไม่รู้เรื่องอ่ะค่ะใช่
แล้วเราก็รู้สึกแบบทำไมตำรวจพูดดีๆได้มย
ทำไมต้องพูดแบบน่ากลัวด้วยอ่ะปกติคนไทยก็
กลัวอยู่แล้วไม่อยากคุยกับคุณอืครูเรียม
อ่ะเวลาครูเรียมขนาดครูเรียมไปไปแจ้งความ
ว่าของหายตำรวจยังบอกเลยว่าหาไม่เจอหรอก
ใช่เรียมก็เลยแบบเฮ้อตำรวจช่วยดูหน่อยไม่
ไม่คิดไม่คิดจะช่วยเรียมเลยหรออะไรแบบ
เนี้ยเรียมก็เลยแบบเออเออไม่ได้ไม่ช่วย
จริงๆหรือว่าตอนที่โทรศัพท์เรียมหายเรียม
ก็คิดว่าเค้าจะแบบไปหาดูกล้องวงจรปิดสถาน
ที่ใกล้ๆให้แบบเนี้ยแต่ว่าตำรวจก็เลยบอก
เรียมว่ามีกล้องวงจรปิดมั้ยให้เหลี่มไปหา
มาให้เค้าเพื่อที่จะไปจับตัวผู้ร้ายอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยเขาคก็บอกว่าถ้าเกิดไม่มีก็จับ
ไม่ไดู้้เลยเออใช่ๆผู้หญิงอ่ะคือเนี้ยไม่
ให้คุณหญิงไปเองนะคะแต่ว่า 2 ปีที่แล้ว
มั้มันจะมีแบบคุณน้าเนี่ยเค้าประสบ
อุบัติเหตุใช่มั้ยรถมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยชน
อ่าน้าชายนะคะแล้วเขาก็แบบเออเสียชีวิต
อ่ะเนาะแล้วทีเนี้ยมันก็มีเหมือนจำไม่ได้
ว่าเป็นปั๊มน้ำมันหรือเปล่าอ่ะไม่แน่ใจ
อ่ะค่ะแล้วทีเนี้ยเราก็ไปแจ้งความใช่มั้ย
บอกตำรวจเออว่าเพราะว่าคนชาวบ้านบ้าน
เนี่ยเค้าเห็นว่ามันมีรถรถบรรทุกที่มัน
ขับมาขับแข่งกันมาอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเออตำรวจ
ก็บอกว่าก็ไปถามปั๊มน้ำมันว่ามีมีกล้อง
มั้ยให้เราอ่ะไปถามเองเออพอเราไปถามปั๊ม
น้ำมันก็บอกว่าอ๋อวันนั้นกล้องใช้ไม่ได้
อืเขาอาจจะไม่อยากยุ่งก็ได้ใช่ๆค่ะเขาก็
อาจจะไม่อยากยุ่งกับตำรวจอ่ะเค้าก็แบบไม่
อยากให้ตำรวจต้องมาวุ่นวายกับงานของเค้า
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเราก็เลยแบบคือถ้าให้เราคน
ธรรมดาไปถามปั๊มน้ำมันเค้าก็ไม่บอกเรา
อยู่แล้วว่ามีใช่
มั้ยใช่แล้วเขาคก็จะคิดว่าแบบเป็นใครอยู่
ดีๆมาขอดูกล้องวงจรปิด
อืใช่นั่นแหละเราก็งงว่าเอ้าทำไมตำรวจไม่
ไปขอดูเองแต่ตำรวจเ้าก็แบบเหมือนเค้าก็
ไม่ได้อะไรเค้าก็รู้สึกก็อุบัติเหตุอ่ะ
เออคนก็ตายไปแล้วทำอะไรได้แต่เราก็แบบเรา
ก็อยากรู้ไงว่าใครที่มันเป็นคนขับรถไม่ดี
เออเค้าทำผิดมั้ยตำรวจต้องจับเ้ามยใช่
เพราะว่าเรียมก็ดูในดูในหนังดูในละครไง
ที่แบบตำรวจเาจะเป็นคนไปหาหลักฐานไงเรีย
ก็เลยคิดว่าเรื่องที่เกิดขึ้นจริงๆอ่ะพอ
เรียมไปแจ้งความกับตำรวจตำรวจต้องเป็นแบบ
นั้นอันนั้นคือความคิดเมว่าตำรวจต้องไป
เอาภาพไปเอาวิดีโอจาก CCTV มาให้เราแล้ว
ก็ไปตามจับคนร้ายให้เราอันนั้นคือสิ่งที่
เรียมคิดแต่ที่เจอก็เหมือนกับผู้หญิงนั่น
แหละที่แบบมีกล้องวงจรปิดมั้ยไปเอา
มาเรา
หรอเออใชใช่จริงๆนะแบบทุกคนนะคะแบบผู้
หญิงก็เคยอ่านมาเหมือนกันคนไทยหลายๆคนน่ะ
ถ้าเวลามีอุบัติเหตุเกิดขึ้นอะไรกับคนใน
ครอบครัวรถชนอะไรก็ได้หรือว่าของหายที่
ไหนก็ได้อเขาจะให้เราอ่ะไปเอากล้องวงจร
ปิดมาเองอแล้วก็เราแบบแล้วเราจะไปขอเค้า
ได้ยังไงใครเขาจะให้เราอืแล้วเจะเชื่อเรา
เหรอว่าูหญิงจะเดินไปสมมุติว่าครูหญิงทำ
กระเป๋าเงินหายที่ที่เว-อวแล้วผู้หญิงจะ
เดินเข้าไปแบบเซเว่นคะคือฉันทำเงินหาย
เมื่อวานตอน 20:00 นขอกล้องวงจรปิดได้มย
อืว่าแบบเออตอน 20:00 นเมื่อวานเนี่ยมี
ใครเดินมาแล้วก็เก็บกระเป๋าเงินไปหรือ
เปล่าเซเว่นเค้าก็ไม่ให้เราอยู่แล้วอืใช่
มั้ยเพราะว่าวีีดีโอในกล้องอ่ะเป็นของ
เค้าใช่แล้วเก็ต้องทำทำงานอะไรของเาอีก
เยอะมากอืแต่ถ้าตำรวจไปขออันเนี้ยเขาอาจ
จะต้องให้ไงใช่เพราะว่านี่คือตำรวจเออใช่
ค่ะเราก็เลยแบบถ้าเราต้องทำเองทุกอย่าง
แล้วเราจะต้องไปหาตำรวจทำไมหรอก็ไม่ไม่
ค่อยได้ไปส่วนมากถ้าเกิดต้องทำเอกสารใหม่
กระเป๋าหายแล้วบัตรต้องทำ ATM บัตรประชา
ชนใหม่แบบนั้นน่ะคือต้องไปแต่ว่าถ้าเกิด
หายแบบหายแบบที่ไม่ต้องทำเอกสารไม่ต้องทำ
บัตรใหม่เรียมก็ไม่เป็นไรอ่ะไม่ต้องแจ้ง
ความถ้าโทรศัพท์หายอีกแล้วเอากลับคืนมา
เองไม่ได้ก็เอไม่ต้องแจ้งความก็ได้อืก็
ช่างมันเพราะว่าแจ้งความก็เสียเวลาแล้วก็
ตำรวจก็ไม่ช่วยอะไรด้วยเราก็ไม่ได้คืน
อยู่ดีใช่ๆค่ะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะเคยไปทำทำ
อะไรที่สถานีตำรวจหรือว่าโรงพักหรือเปล่า
อืใช่ถ้าเคยที่ใดประเทศไทยนะก็คอมเมนต์
บอกเราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยหมด
เวลาแล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงกับครูเรียม
ต้องไปก่อนนะคะใช่ค่ะแล้วเจอกันในคลิป
หน้านะคะครูหญิงได้ค่ะคลิปนี้ก็ไปก่อนนะ
คะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ
บาย
บ